today on the matt wall show it's not
enough to tolerate accept or even
celebrate the lgbt left demands that you
participate which is why some major
league baseball players are getting
backlash for not wearing an lgbt pride
flag on their uniforms we'll discuss
also a lawmaker in california now says
he wants drag to be a mandatory
curriculum requirement for children in
school these groomer freaks are
officially out of control and a
hollywood actor gives a speech about
guns during the white house press
briefing for some reason plus the
leftist d.a of san francisco is recalled
for turning his city into a
crime-plagued wasteland but will liberal
voters actually learn their lesson i i
tend to doubt it we'll talk about all
that and more today on the matt well
show
[Music]
you know if you're thinking of buying a
new home it's in your best interest to
act now review your budget start the
pre-approval process and get ahead of
rising rates real estate will continue
to be a healthy investment if you're
getting a competitive deal from a lender
who cares that's why i recommend
american financing it's america's home
for home loans their salary-based
mortgage consultants can get your rate
locked for up to 120 days so you have
time to shop without being at risk of a
higher rate you're also going to get a
custom loan that's designed around your
needs
i mean it's really a no pressure
experience that's focused on you and
they never charge up front or hidden
fees
they make it worth your time to learn
more so you're saving money you're also
you're not dealing with a lot of red
tape it's very easy to do very
convenient all you got to do is give
them a call now at
866-569-4711 that's
866-569-4711-866-569-4711 or visit
americanfinancing.net
nmls18234 nmls consumeraccess.org
you know seinfeld might be one of the
most overrated shows in history but it
did have moments of real resonance for
instance there was a scene in a season
seven that has proven to be downright
prophetic in the episode kramer decides
to participate in a um
a charity aids walk to raise money and
awareness about the disease and the
organizers offer him a red aids ribbon
to wear but then he declines doesn't
wear the ribbon and they tell him that
he has to wear the ribbon and he says
well that's why i don't want to wear it
because you're telling me i have to and
soon he's surrounded by an angry lynch
mob and beaten senseless for his refusal
to wear the crowd's chosen symbol
heroically though he stands firm and is
made to pay the price for his insult
against conformity now as many people on
social media have pointed out
there are striking parallels between
that scene and uh many things that
happen in modern society but especially
the situation playing out right now
in major league baseball where five
players on the tampa bay rays are being
condemned
for not wearing the ribbon except the
ribbon in this case is a gay pride
logo as espn reports a number of tampa
bay raised players decided not to wear
rainbow colored logos on their uniforms
as part of the team's annual pride night
on saturday that recognized the lgbtq
community among players who elected to
remove the logos were pitchers jason
adam jalen beaks brooks rayleigh brooks
rayleigh rather brooks brooks rayleigh
brooks rayleigh uh jeffrey springs and
ryan thompson according to the tampa bay
times adam was elected to speak for the
group after the game saying it was a
faith-based decision for many of them
he said quote so it's a hard decision
adam told the tampa bay times because
ultimately we all said we uh what we
want is them to know that all are
welcome and loved here but when we put
it on our bodies i think a lot of guys
decided that it's just a lifestyle that
maybe
not that they look down on anybody or
think differently it's just that maybe
we don't want to encourage it if we
believe in jesus who's encouraged us to
live a lifestyle that would abstain from
that behavior it's not judgmental it's
not looking down it's just what we
believe the lifestyle he's encouraged us
to live for our good not to withhold
but again we love these men and women we
care about them and we want them to feel
safe and welcome here
now
there's nothing in your face or
confrontational here i mean he's going
out of his way uh i think way too far
out of the way actually to try to you
know make clear that it's not judgmental
it's nothing like that it's just they
simply don't want to wear a gay pride
symbol on their bodies
bodily autonomy right well we know
that's already out the window because
there's a part of this another trend of
forcing people to wear things on their
bodies and so we got rid of the masks
now but now you have to wear the the
rainbow maybe wear that over your face
that's the next step
but why should they have to i mean
why should this even be an issue why
should any baseball player be put in
this position they're playing baseball
why do we need athletes who aren't even
gay to express gay pride what does that
even mean i mean how can you express
pride in a in a lifestyle that you don't
even live
and if everyone else on the team is
wearing the stupid thing um does it
matter if a few of them don't well the
answer is of course yes it matters a lot
the alphabet club demands total
unanimous fealty and allegiance anything
less is an assault on their very
existence
and so the inevitable outrage ensued
fueled as always by the corporate media
many headlines were feverishly published
about this incident because you know
because five pla baseball players not
wearing a rainbow on their uniform is
headline news now in america
a new york times article on the subject
deserves special notice i think here's
the headline
this is what it says
rey's players undercut pride night by
not wearing rainbow logos this is like
me accusing my jewish neighbor of
undercutting christmas by not having a
giant inflatable santa in his front yard
now the writer tyler kepner explains
something was missing in the top of the
eighth inning on saturday at tropicana
field in st petersburg florida the tampa
bay rays used two relief pitchers that
inning the left-handers brooks rayleigh
or brooks as i call him and jalen beaks
who wore jerseys without a patch on
their right sleeve this was not a
manufacturer's error or an equipment
manager's mistake the patch was the
rey's starburst emblem rendered in
rainbow colors
like the tb logo on the team's cap as
part of the team's pride night promotion
rayleigh beaks and a few other teammates
chose to wear caps and jerseys without
the rainbow accents later kepner writes
without a hint of intentional irony
he says that the pride logos are
supposed to represent quote
unity without judgment
and in the very next paragraph he
delights in the fact that the players
without the patches according to him
performed poorly on the field and their
team lost the game
so
you deserve to lose for being judgmental
you worthless ugly bigots
basically the message we've certainly
learned that uh we cannot expect these
people to maintain a consistent message
from one sentence to the next or even
within the same sentence
other baseball players have hopped on
the outrage bandwagon a guy named brian
ruby who is openly gay
complained to usa today that he was
offended and his tummy was very much
hurt because five guys didn't wear a
rainbow ruby whined saying
it always baffles me when guys use jesus
as their excuse to discriminate like
wasn't jesus the guy who preached love
thy neighbor this is about being a good
teammate when guys go out of their way
to make a point of opposing pride night
they're sending a clear message that
people like me just aren't welcome in
baseball it's a reminder that even on
the one night we get to be proud of
ourselves at the ballpark we're all
still second-class citizens it's as
simple as that
you're a second-class citizen because
someone's not wearing a rainbow on their
jersey
right
go out of their way
discriminate here's what happened the
team said to them hey most of us are
gonna wear these uh these ugly rainbows
celebrating the gay lifestyle for some
reason uh you should wear one too and
they said
uh no thank you
and that was it they didn't have to go
out of their way they were simply like
they continued going the same way they'd
always been going and
it's you who has to go out of your way
to be offended by it
many people on the left are as always as
they like to say willing to put in the
work when it comes to getting offended
including even in congress where
congressman ted lou
condemned jason adam one of the players
for citing christianity as his excuse to
not wear the pride flag lou tweeted
jesus is about love not about hating
people who are different from you
yes because if you aren't wearing a gay
pride symbol on your body at all times
you hate gay people
though i must note that ted lou himself
does not often wear gay pride symbols
why does ted liu hate gay people very
troubling
but of all the shrill harpies shrieking
over the fact that a few guys didn't
have a rainbow on their uniform
none can out shrill or out shriek sports
reporter sarah spain
who spoke out about the issue on espn
earlier this week and uh
you just have to hear this for yourself
listen
pride is about inclusion so you don't
love them and you don't welcome them if
you're not willing to wear the patch
okay i gotta i got
to just stop it there for just one
second because because
you don't love them and you don't
welcome them if you aren't willing to
wear the patch that is literally from
seinfeld i mean she is almost verbatim
recreating the seinfeld scene with that
statement leftists continue to break out
beyond the bounds of parody um and it
doesn't get any better from there but
let's keep listening
and calling it a lifestyle reveals to me
that you've done not even a modicum of
research or understanding on this topic
it's what tends to happen when a
privileged class isn't affected by
things this is not just about baseball
that religious exemption bs which is
used in sport and otherwise also allows
for people to be denied health care jobs
apartments
children
prescriptions all sorts of rights and so
we have to stop tiptoeing around it
because we're trying to protect people
who are trying to be bigoted from asking
for them to be exempt from it when the
very people that they are bigoted
against are suffering the consequences
when you say trying to be bigoted
they're trying to use religious
exemptions
to affect the opportunities
services
of available resources for people who
are lgbtq plus
you see all those guys there i mean
they're they're they're even worse than
her because they're all just sitting
there including the the you know the
moderator here
what she's saying is complete nonsense
and they know it but they're like well
worried you know there's a slight
skepticism on their face but they're too
afraid to say that is the stupidest
thing i've ever heard
you ma'am have set back female sports
reporters 50 years with this with
everything you just said there dear god
woman that's what they should say what
they want to say but they're not going
to say it
religious exemption
from wearing a patch
and not wearing the patch will affect
the opportunities and resources of lgbt
people
what
so there are lgbt people today who are
trying to what rent an apartment but the
rental agency is saying sorry folks
jason adam of the tampa bay rays didn't
uh wear a rainbow on his jersey on
sunday therefore you can't have an
apartment because you're gay
is that how this works
also note by the way how she said that
denied children i thought that was very
very revealing also
um you know they're denied health care
they're denied apartments they're denied
children now forgetting about the fact
that we're trying to connect this to a
rainbow pride patch um
the way in what she means by that is
like an adoption
so
she talks about children like they're
just another sort of product that
somebody might want whether you're
denied children
you know because you go to the store you
uh
you buy some shoes
man you get get some children
that's how she sees it
as a sort of commodity anyway
this is total
delusional hysterical nonsense coming
from somebody who
while accusing others of tiptoeing
around is actually tiptoeing around her
own point and true agenda what she wants
to say and what she believes is that
there must be total conformity to her
worldview no other worldview should
exist and if any others do exist they
should subordinate themselves to her
worldview and in her worldview there is
a hierarchy of identities
and the alphabet club is at the top of
the totem pole you must show deference
and submission to them you must even
express pride in their sexual
proclivities
you have to sit back
and and be filled with pride i'm so
proud of you so proud of you for being
gay
what does that even mean well nobody
knows but that's what you have to do
here's the flight path of progressivism
it's important to understand how it
works okay
this is how it always goes
it would have been nice if everybody
picked up on this like 30 years ago but
let's pick up on it now okay so first
they demand tolerance
and then they say tolerance is not
enough they demand acceptance acceptance
and tolerance are not the same they're
often lumped together not they're not
the same you can tolerate something
simply by not interfering with it right
you're just allowing it to exist but
if you accept it
then you're affirming it you're agreeing
to it
this is why we might say that somebody
accepts an offer or accepts an answer
they're receiving it affirmatively
they're agreeing to it
but acceptance is not enough either
next they say that you must do more than
tolerate you must do more than accept
you must celebrate
they need you to pick up the pom-poms
and stand on the sideline and and cheer
you have to give standing ovations you
have to clap for them until your hands
are raw like the sort of a scenes we see
out of north korea where throngs of
dead-eyed people are forced to applaud
abroriously for dear leader while
someone holds a gun to their head just
off camera
but even that is not enough the final
stage
okay the the stage that we're in
right now as a culture stage four
is participation
it's not enough to tolerate or to accept
or to celebrate now we must actively
participate put down the pompoms you're
in the game now sport okay you're
playing
wear the patch wave the flag use the
pronoun
you must be an eager and convincing
participant
forced conversion
mandatory baptism into the religious
cult that's the final step
now if you submit to the first step you
will be taken all the way to the final
step by shear inertia that's why the
only answer
that you should give
when the left comes along and starts
making demands
is to just say no
okay
and and to keep saying no
and to never give them an inch
the only mistake these five players made
was in providing an explanation for
their refusal i mean
they should be commended for refusing it
takes courage it shouldn't take courage
but it does
but to explain
is to agree
that your choice requires a defense it
doesn't
the burden of explanation is on the
other side
they must explain to you
why you should wear the patch
what pressing urgent need is there for
it what what what good thing will be
achieved
why are you asking me to do this
explain yourself and make it snappy i'm
i'm running out of patience
this is the way it's supposed to work
not the other way around when the left
is constantly coming around and saying
oh here's this new thing we should do
and then people
on the other side are frantically trying
to explain well i don't think i should
be able to do that no
no
this is your idea you explain it to me
you defend yourself you're on the hook
give me an explanation explain yourself
oh you can't you're stuttering and
muttering you can't even explain then
get the hell out of my face please
please leave me alone
why should i wear the damn patch what
exactly is it uh because lgbt people
need to rent apartments and have
healthcare what does that have to do
with a patch oh you can't explain that
get out of my face
they can't explain themselves
they can't explain anything as i
discovered in my film what is a woman
which you can find at whatever.com
they simply make demands
and they expect that you'll go alone
learn to say no
and say it loud
and say it often
now let's get to our five
[Music]
headlines you know life happens fast and
it can end
even faster it's a morbid way to start
uh you picture yourself living to a ripe
old age but it doesn't always work out
that way uh you could die any moment you
could die right now you could walk
outside right now hit by a bus okay
death is lurking around the corner and
if it hits you you got to have a plan in
pace place otherwise the state the
people you hate the people who are going
to try to indoctrinate your kids take
your guns steal your freedom they're
going to step in and take control of
your assets when you're gone they're
gonna determine what legacy you leave
behind so don't let the state decide
what happens to your children should
something happen to you which again
could happen at any moment
uh the veil keeping you from one world
to the next is very very thin so don't
let the state decide um who gets your
useless nfts or comic books instead take
five minutes and set up a will through
epic will starting at just 119 you
choose who raises your kids you choose
who gets your crap after you've gone
because you don't get to choose when you
die because it could again happen
anytime here's what i want you to do go
to epicwell.com and use promo code walsh
you'll get a 10 discount on epic will's
complete will package that yes could
take only five minutes to set up many of
our families daily wire are now
protected thanks to epic will why don't
you do the same go to epicwheel.com
enter promo code walsh and do something
for you and your family today before you
die
but you know what if you really want to
wear a patch which shows your
virtue and what a good person you are
then don't wear the rainbow patch go to
dailywire.com and to the uh matt walsh
store and we have our patch program we
have all kinds of matt wall show patches
including a what is a woman patch that
you could pick up now and i'm thinking
do we have a virtue signal i think we
need a patch that actually because this
is what this is all about i mean we kind
of cover everything all at once so maybe
there
maybe we should get a patch that just
says i don't know it just says virtue on
it or something or virtue signal we just
need we could sort of cover all the
bases and then if anyone ever does come
along and say oh you need to wear a
rainbow patch then you could say no no i
got the virtue patch i got to virtue
it's just that covers all the stuff any
whatever the current thing is i already
got it
current thing patch maybe we'll work it
out we need something like that okay
thinking on our feet here um
so
we just talked about
the flight path the trajectory right the
uh the process tolerate accept celebrate
participate
okay like burn let's burn it into our
minds that's the way it always goes
tolerate accept
celebrate participate so here it is
again okay from the post-millennial it
says in response to a texas state
representative announcing that he will
file legislation to ban drag shows from
having children in their audience
california state senator scott weiner
proposed offering drag queen curriculum
in schools
responding to a tweet from
representative brian slayton of texas in
which he announced the legislation
weiner wrote
and it's just
i mean the fact that his name is weiner
is it's just
so perfect he said uh this guy just gave
me a bill idea offering drag queen 101
as part of the k-12 curriculum
attending drag queen story time will
satisfy the requirements
okay now
you might think
you see the tweet there you might think
this is slightly tongue-in-cheek
and even if it is it's still
uh
horrifying and disgusting and this guy's
a groomer scumbag
but oh no this is not a joke
this is not a joke from this guy he will
introduce that legislation
and we'll have more examples of other
legislation that he's introduced before
just uh just to show you that you know
he could put his money where his mouth
is in fact we'll continue it says in
2020 weiner author authored a bill
that would end discrimination against
lgbt people quote unquote by providing
exemptions from the sex offender
registry the bill sb-145 made exemptions
for people who are convicted of certain
offenses as long as a person convicted
is no more than 10 years older than the
minor with the minor being no younger
than 14.
this bill would exempt from mandatory
registration under the act a person
convicted of certain offenses involving
minors if the person is not more than 10
years older than the minor and if that
offense is the only one requiring person
the person to register
and
there were some other ones as well more
recently weiner officer authored a bill
that would authorize the creation of
safe consumption sites within cities and
counties
um so that's another one who's the bill
where people can go and use drugs
also weiner alongside fellow state
senator todd gloria authored a bill that
passed back in 2017 that removes federal
penalties and prison time
for people that knowingly expose a
sexual partner to hiv
so prior to
the weiner coming along he was um
unfortunate phrasing there
prior to this guy it was it was
illegal in the state of california as it
still is i think at least in some states
in the country it should be in every
state to knowingly infect somebody with
hiv as in if you have sex with somebody
and you're hiv positive you have a legal
responsibility to tell them ahead of
time of course that should be the law um
but now
thanks to weiner you can
intentionally and knowingly infect
somebody with hiv and it's not a crime
so that's where that's where this guy's
coming from and that's why when he says
that he's going to make a bill
requiring mandatory drag queen classes
for children oh he'll do it
and i repeat what i said yesterday that
um
[Music]
i very much welcome democrats making
this
their new
cause
okay i don't i don't welcome
these kinds of classes
in public school
of course
though honestly i mean if you're in
california
living in california number one and
number two you're in california you have
your kids in public school in california
then uh
i mean what what do you expect like that
just
that's that's almost inexcusable
at this point
but what i what i welcome and what i
want
is for the democrats to
explicitly come out
just to say what they already think what
we know they think which is that this is
a good thing
and uh to circle the wagons around it so
that everybody else can see another
another great mask off moment for the
left
so that all the normal people out there
however many still exist can see this
and like you can decide do you really
is this is this what you want is this
what you believe in
you want to vote for people support
people who think that we should mix drag
queens and kids
another part of the process aside from
tolerate except celebrate participate
the other thing that you find is um
there's this kind of stages of denial or
how denial kind of morphs into defense
so
um that's the other thing we always see
with the left
so first when it came to this you know
drag queens and kids originally they
said
that's not really happening that's a
it's a it's not it's not happening
that's that's not really a thing this is
all you know it's a it's a right-wing
conspiracy theory
uh there might be a few examples of it
but it that's that's very very rare and
it's a you know it's not a big deal it's
not really happening
and then
how quickly we go from that to
oh it is happening but it's good
it's not happening
okay it is happening but it's good
and then that goes to
it is happening it's good oh and it's
mandatory
so we go from not happening to mandatory
and that thing and that can um that
progress process can play out very
quickly
that can happen within the span of like
hours okay
and i think we're going to see that here
because um
the left has been ramping up as we've
been covering on this show libs of tick
tock on twitter has been um doing a lot
of work to reveal this this is a an
increasing trend now on the left
of uh drag queens and kids and the worst
iteration of that
the most evil form of course is
when the kid is actually enlisted to be
the drag queen so here's something that
lives with tick-tock had
um
this is i i still don't know where i'm
not sure if we know where this happened
but some kind of bar
we have adults
cheering on
uh for a child drag queen
let's
see this for just a moment
let me tell you one of the fiercest
performers yet
you guys haven't seen nothing yet please
give it up for the one the only kingdom
queen
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so you'll see that that is an
actual child that we're talking about
uh i can't even watch this all right we
could turn it off
i mean that's the kind of thing you have
to see it
because if you don't see it then you
won't believe it
i think there's still a lot of people if
you told him that this is happening
that child
drag queens
are dancing for
for adults at gay clubs
you told that say it's an average person
on the street they're going to say
that's not they're not going to believe
you i'm going to believe it's happening
and that's why the work that you know
accounts like lives a tick tock are
doing that's why it's important to see
this is actually happening this is a
real thing
okay and it's not just a couple of
instant instant incidents it's it's
happening all over the place
this is
basically this is you know this is this
is baka bazi okay which is which is uh
afghanistan a lot of our veterans who
spent time in afghanistan unfortunately
um
confronted this and and were very made
very much aware of this uh of this
tradition in the culture among among the
men in
afghanistan or quote-unquote dancing
boys and that's where
um
men in afghanistan will sit around and
they'll watch
uh little boys dressed up as girls
dancing for them and then of course
there's a lot of sexual abuse and child
rape that happens as well
which by the way is is
you know kind of redundant to even say
that because the event itself is child
sexual abuse already
and
you hear about that in afghanistan i
remember hearing about that for the
first time
when we first went into afghanistan
and in this country people were
horrified
and you had veterans coming home from
afghanistan traumatized
by having witnessed and especially
witnessed it and they're not allowed to
do anything about it they're being
instructed by their higher ups that they
can't stop it
coming home traumatized because of that
and then what do you know
15 years later same damn thing is
happening here
and it's being defended
in the mainstream
by leftists and democrats
and let them defend it defend it defend
it loudly loud and proud come on you
just come out come out and and give us
give us your argument
by the way this is the same thing
remember i said that when they propose
something it's up to them to explain it
and defend it
okay you have to force them to do it
because they're playing the same game
with this by the way
there was um
i've seen a lot of this on twitter and
one example is a charlotte climber
i think works for
one of these a human rights campaign or
one of one of these radical trans lgbt
organizations militant
and uh posing the question of well i i
really don't i'm not sure i don't
understand why it's so wrong to mix
children and drag queens could someone
explain to me why it's wrong
so we've heard that a lot from the left
people with platforms prominent people
saying oh i'm open to to understanding
why you guys object to it but why don't
you explain it
okay
we shouldn't need to explain it and we
don't have to explain it that should be
if it's not immediately obvious to you
why it's wrong then that says something
very troubling about you but also let me
flip that around around
um you are the one
proposing this you're the one it's your
side introducing this into the culture
you explain why we need to do it okay
you you give us the defense of it
what's good about it
why do kids need this
kids are getting along just fine they're
they're just being kids they're playing
they're using their imaginations they're
living you know innocent childlike lives
as they should
you're coming along and saying oh you
know you know what they need they need
drag
so that's up to you to defend and
explain
which you can't do
um so far or at least the defense is not
anything that you'll say out loud
because the real reason that you want to
do it is that you have an actual agenda
to sexualize children you don't want to
say that out loud yet anyway
all right this is from the daily wire
says san francisco voters sent
shockwaves throughout the political
world tuesday night removing woke
district attorney chesa bodine from
office ending his disastrous tenure in
office
bodine
could not overcome a coalition of more
safety-minded democrats republicans
independents who were furious over the
rampant property crimes open drug use
persistent retail theft and skyrocketing
number
of certain crimes
the wall street journal reported voters
strongly endorsed ousting the
reform-minded d.a as partial return
showed about 60 of voters supporting the
recall um since putin took office in
january of 2020 burglaries have risen 45
percent
and homicides have increased almost 40
37
that is
that's about as much damage as you could
possibly do in two years
if you're trying to do as much damage as
you possibly can that's the most i think
you could do and and he is trying he was
trying uh 45
increase in property crimes almost 40
increase in murders
and you know i i was in sanford we were
in san francisco shooting the film
it's actually my first time ever being
in san francisco
and i don't plan on going back any time
soon
and there's a you know that's one thing
about these places in california
including san francisco
it's just tragic to see what's happened
to these
cities and to these regions of the
country
tragic in general but also because it's
it's still so geographically beautiful
and um you can still go out you know to
the coast and
it's it's a beautiful sight when you're
looking out you know if you can because
now you have your back on all of the
feces on the ground and the homeless
encampments and the people shooting up
heroin needles lying on the street you
turn your back on that and just look out
to the ocean it looks quite beautiful
and we are wasting this
this beauty
on on
what has become of san francisco
which is quite tragic and i can remember
being there walking around and i i kind
of you know i didn't
this is another reason why you have to
kind of you have to see it for yourself
uh i had heard all the reports about how
these cities that were run by these
soros da's have turned into third world
countries and i part of me thought that
might be a slight exaggeration
walking through san francisco driving
through it it is not an exaggeration it
is a hellscape it is dystopian
and that is thanks entirely to these
progressive left-wing policies
and that is because
left-wing policies
make people's lives worse
in very obvious direct ways
if you are living under the boot of a of
a leftist
your life is going to be worse
you're going to be less prosperous less
safe less healthy
um
not as happy
in general
and that's that's the difference
left-wing policies
everybody can see
how it hurts them
very direct very immediate they're
making your life worse and they're doing
it on purpose
and voters you know they'll rebel
against in you know this individual
this d.a we got to get rid of him he's
made our life worse
but oftentimes the voters in these
cities they still don't they don't
connect the dots they don't add two plus
two
and so they're still going to vote for
more democrats
and just keep voting for democrats they
vote for a democrat makes their life
worse and they say oh that democrat is
bad let's fall for another one uh their
life gets even worse oh okay well he's
no good let's get another one life gets
even worse and they just never quite
understand
um
as opposed to
on the right
you know the left says that living under
right wing
supposed right-wing policies will make
your life worse but they have to do a
lot of work to convince you
that your life has been made worse
that's the interesting thing all of the
um consequences of living under
conservative policies
you don't really see them and so they
have to do marches in the street and
wear the handmade costumes right and uh
and just tell you no no this is terrible
don't you see how terrible things are
we have to walk around in our handmade
costumes well you don't have to walk
around and that you're choosing to well
yes but it represents something simple
what does it represent
women are being oppressed by these
policies how
but you said you're being oppressed
you're out here protesting it doesn't
seem like if you're being oppressed
doesn't seem like you'd be allowed to do
that
so there's a lot of effort they have to
go through
to convince you that your life has been
made worse by conservative policies
because in fact your life is not made
worse by them
whereas on the right we have the
advantage of we don't have to convince
you of anything we don't have to
convince you that your life has been
damaged by left-wing policies all we
have to say is just look at your front
look out your window walk down the
street that's all you have to do
it's right there in front of you
all right let's move to this joy reid of
msnbc had some great wisdom and insight
on gun violence as always always look to
joy read for wisdom and uh she's happy
to provide it so let's listen to her
definitely not online where anger and
alienation and fear just feast on places
like 4chan and 8chan and they know it
and rupert murdoch's marionettes are
pulling those themes right onto their
primetime shows
republicans have literally made bringing
trump and his dangerous paranoid style
back onto twitter into a political
rallying cry and okay set aside
ideological or emotional safety we're
not allowed to feel physically safe
anywhere in america thanks to
republicans ironclad partnership with
the bloodsoak nra which long ago quit
the gun safety business and has been
working for decades to ensure that the
most lethal arms get into as many
alienated 18 and 19 year old in cell
hands as possible so that we can't feel
safe at walmart at the supermarket
at bible study or church service
at the salon
at the hospital if god forbid some guy
gets mad at his doctor for not giving
him opioids at a nightclub at a concert
even at a funeral
or at school
whether you're in high school or you're
10
and in the fourth grade
in america and only in america you are
literally rolling the dice
um
perfect illustration of what we just
talked about trying to convince us so
she's trying to convince us that
conservative policies and i say
conservative policies but really in this
case we're just talking about
constitutional policies so kind of one
in the same
um
those policies of
respecting your
god-given rights to self-defense
respecting the second amendment try to
convince us that it makes our lives
worse and so she's listing all the
places where you're unsafe because of
the nra and because of gun rights
and um
of course the places that almost all the
places that she listed statistically
you are still
quite safe in uh all those places
statistically doesn't mean you're 100
safe doesn't mean nothing bad will ever
happen but
statistically like
if you're you know
you go to walmart in a in a suburban
neighborhood
and you go to walmart every day your
entire life and
you're almost certainly not going to be
the victim of a some kind of mass
shooting in the process
so she's listing all these places
what's the one place she doesn't list
these all the places where you can't
feel safe
just walking around
the one place she doesn't list is where
almost all of the gun violence happens
which is in the inner city
in all the cities that are run by
democrats
so trying to convince us oh you're not
safe here you're not safe there you're
not safe there um
you know you're actually not safe is
walking down the street in one of these
cities
where again almost all of the gun
violence happens
gonna overlook that
well speaking of gun violence we we
heard from joy reid we also heard
yesterday for some reason from matthew
mcconaughey now
i haven't i haven't actually looked into
this i i don't even i'm not sure what
the reason was
like the the ostensible reason
for bringing matthew mcconaughey for
white house press briefing to talk about
guns
i know the actual reason the reason is
that he's a celebrity he's oh listen to
him he's a celebrity but he was up there
giving a little speech about
guns and let's listen to him
families of the deceased mothers fathers
sisters brothers texas rangers hunters
border patrol and responsible gun owners
who won't give up their second amendment
right to bear arms and you know what
they all said
we want secure and safe schools and we
want gun laws that won't make it so easy
for the bad guys to get these damn guns
so
we know it's on the table
we need to invest in mental health care
we need to save for schools
we need to restrain sensationalized
media coverage
we need to restore our family values
that's another restore thanks thanks for
that uh mcconaughey
uh so i looked it up okay so he's from
uvalde texas and that's why
that's why he's given a speech at the
white house press conference
because he's from uvalde
why him though why not just pull any
random go to the gas station just pull
somebody and say you want to give a
speech to the white house press
conference you're from here
they would have just as much if not more
credibility than matthew mcconaughey
uh so
let's listen to him to matthew
mcconaughey because he is very good at
pretending to be people
that's his resume that's his
qualification that's why that's why he's
at the white house press briefing
live
national television because listen this
guy is very good at pretending
and so we should listen to him about
guns
not that uh what we hear from official
white house sources is any better we did
also hear eventually from karen
jean-pierre
the new white house press secretary and
she was asked about as we got away from
guns talking about the economy and she
says that actually your eyes are
deceiving you uh the economy is in a
pretty good place listen
what we're trying to say what i'm trying
to say to you is that the economy is in
a better place than it has been
historically and so we feel here at this
administration and other experts as well
is that we feel that we are in a good
position to take on inflation
yeah it's all it's it's good it's
you feel like you're suffering but
you're actually not everything is fine
the economy is better than it has been
historically i love the phrasing there
it's so broad and open-ended then it has
been historically so what she's saying
is that
um
there's at least
one other point in american history
where the economy has been worse in
order for that statement to be true you
just need then it has been historically
in order for that to be true you just
need there to be one other occasion in
american history when the economy was
worse than this and then you could say
well it's better than it has been
historically so if it's if we're in
better shape than we were let's say uh
right in the height of the civil war or
something then uh yeah we're better off
than we have been historically
all right i want to move to this before
we get to the comment section i cannot
neglect to mention this story uh some
topless pro-abortion feminists protested
during a wnba game last night protested
over abortion
um
i think it was very nice of them to
stage this protest in a forum
where nobody would see it
and
now we're going to see it though because
i'm going to play it so let's let's play
some of the footage of this go ahead and
play when they are running running
around the court
no shirt on
security tracking down
someone took a tumble there
that is uh i gotta say that's the most
athleticism
i've ever seen on a wnba court
mostly because i've never seen a wnba
court
i didn't even know they played on accord
that's the honest truth i thought that
they just played they picked somebody's
driveway for each game and they played
there i didn't so that's great that's a
good job uh ladies you get a whole court
to yourself i mean literally get it to
yourself you know because no one's there
um
it was pretty rude of the protesters
honestly i mean the fan in the audience
didn't pay to see that
actually he really didn't pay to see it
he paid to see an imagine dragons
concert and went to the wrong stadium
and then was kind of stuck there from
what i understand according to reports
um
i've read actually that uh this is
interesting that after that disruption
that they decided not to start the game
back up uh because the ref said there's
just no point you know and plus he was
hungry and wanted to eat dinner and so
they just kind of ended it
didn't matter anyway it's a wnba game so
anyway
that's what happened there
let's move now to the comment section
[Music]
who's to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
henry cross says to be real honest i
thought the groomer mob would have
already successfully taken down matt's
twitter account i thought there was no
way his account would have survived the
release of this film but it did and it
wowed me so here's to scrappy resilient
matt cheers i am with you in being
stunned by that um
by that reality also
i i didn't think i didn't know if any of
my social media platforms would survive
i don't want to
you know i want to count my uh
chickens before they hatch
and
but but
yeah i am a little bit surprised but
it's not for lack of trying i mean they
have been mass reporting all of my
accounts for days and days and days
and yet i remain now i say that i expect
it to get de-platformed and all that not
because i'm breaking the rules on these
social media platforms uh but just
because you know the the rule we know
what the real rule is is that if you're
a conservative then
they're going to do what they can to get
rid of you so we'll see johnny said
johnny hollywood says i got fired from a
waiter job at a real nice hotel chain
because hr overheard a joke i made with
two other males about my penis and i
lost my job when the joke was repeated
back to me in
writing and
that that's never good by the way to
hear the joke repeat it back to you in
writing i think first of all you lose a
lot of the
it's just that's not the context for a
joke i think it loses something in
translation um and you said it was uh
documented so that the witch really does
have power it's insane uh yeah well this
is this is what a lot of these hr
departments corporate hr departments do
they i mean that's why we heard from the
one hr
woman in that video the wicked witch of
the west
uh she was delighting in the fact i mean
she said she wasn't just speaking for
herself she said that hey we and hr
we're a bunch of women and we're angry
and we hate you
and
everyone watching that video who's
worked in the corporate world you know
you see that you think well yeah i know
i've noticed
your whole existence is just to find
reasons to
make my life harder and hopefully if you
can get rid of me um
uh let's see
mike says imagine being so insecure in
your identity that you feel very your
your very existence is threatened by a
documentary made by a high school
educated flannel-wearing podcast hosts i
know exactly exactly
um i have never i i tell you i'm a
documentary i'm a fan of documentaries
um
that's why it's so thrilling to now be
able to call myself a documentarian
myself identify that way
and i have never i've seen documentaries
i didn't like um i've seen documentaries
i disagreed with
i have never
felt physically assaulted by a
documentary
um i've never
screamed out in pain
because i thought that i was going to
die
watching the documentary i've never been
watching a documentary and then
felt like that uh like back to the
future where you know he's looking at
the photograph and the images of his
family is like slowly disappearing i
never i never looked down at myself and
just watched myself slowly disappear as
my existence was erased by a documentary
i don't even know how that would work
but i think it does show that you're
certainly not very secure in your
identity
uh 4g mama says god bless you your
courage is amazing your willingness to
be a martyr for truth is exactly what
the world needs may god and your
guardian angel protect you well thank
you for that but one correction
is uh i'm actually not willing to be a
martyr um
that's not something i'm just gonna
accept anyway
i i don't wanna i'm not gonna be a
martyr
the i'd rather make a the other guy the
martyr there's a guy who wants to make
me a martyr he's like no i'll how about
you instead
but i appreciate it
sarah says matt so what's the deal with
the sandwich at the end of the film was
that supposed to be a sexist trope in
the movie yeah the the sandwich now now
we really got into spoilers but i guess
it's been a week since the movie came
out so we could talk a little bit we get
a little more spoilery
in in our discussions of the film and
i've
been asked this question a lot um
especially by the uh by feminist i did
an interview with laura dodsworth who's
a journalist in the uk and she did an
interview for uh called the critic
magazine
and it was a good interview she was very
fair she did a write up you can go and
check it out
but she also asked me about this because
this apparently is a big debate among
especially uk
so-called gender-critical feminists
about the last scene in the movie when i
go home and i talk to my wife
and she tells me what a woman is but
she's in the kitchen and she's making a
sandwich
when she tells me this and so i was
asked was this some sort of
was there some sort of deeper
significance to that what was i trying
to say with the sandwich
um
what's what's the symbolism
and the honest truth is there's just no
symbolism we just we just needed her to
be sort of doing something in the scene
and to give the answer and then get back
to what she was doing because part of
the point is that she's she's sort of
situated in her daily life
situated in in you know her life and her
existence her identity as a woman has a
mom as a as a wife and all of that
and so she's not sitting around naval
gazing
thinking what is what is a what is my
identity what is this what is that right
this is the whole the whole question of
gender ideology the reason why this has
become a question is because of all the
it's a luxury belief it's it's all the
naval gazing in the west people just
sitting around with nothing else to do
and um looking back within their own
egos and asking themselves how do i feel
how do i feel about how i feel
if you live your life
and are situated within your life
and are
confident in who you are
then a lot of these questions almost
don't exist they're quite obvious so
that's what we wanted to communicate
that she gives the answer then gets back
to what she's doing
however
i'm quite happy that people are i think
it's a it's a good sign with a movie
when people are picking apart each
little scene and looking for all the
deeper symbolism and significance
and i will also say and i said this in
the interview with uh with laura
that
like it didn't occur to me when we were
shooting the scene that somebody would
be offended by that aspect of it
if somebody had told me and said you
know people might be offended by this
i would have said i don't care we're
still going to do the scene this way
so i don't want anyone to think that we
were trying to avoid being offensive
either that's certainly not the case
we're just doing the scene that's all
but you can interpret it how you want
well what is a woman is a huge success
way beyond my wildest dreams to be
honest with you so thank you for that we
gained more subscribers the day of the
premiere than on any other day in daily
wire history last night this film became
the number one most popular movie at
home on rotten tomatoes that were beaten
out uh you know streaming films on on
platforms with millions and more
subscribers than we are still haven't
gotten any mainstream critic reviews yet
and that's perfectly fine uh this topic
is is more important now than it ever
has been before it's about protecting
women and children
and it's also about as i always say
first and foremost about defending and
protecting the truth because the truth
matters um and that's why with this film
we're changing the gender ideology
conversation and one of the ways we're
changing the conversation is by having a
conversation about it because they don't
want us to talk about it as we've seen
without your support none of this will
be possible so from all of us at daily
wire we want to say thank you and we
also want to let you know that tara on
the prairie premieres june 14th and uh
that means that look if you became a
daily wire subscriber
um it's uh it's not just for uh what is
a woman we've got tons of great stuff
coming up this month and
uh from there on if you remember when
hollywood and disney tried to cancel
gina carano two days after that gina
after gina was canceled daley wire
picked her up and announced that she'd
be starring in and producing our next
original film
and then we actually made the film and i
for one am really looking forward to
this exactly the kind of movies that we
should be making is tara on the prairie
so go to dailywire.com subscribe to join
us and get exclusive access to our
entire content library
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
we have um something unprecedented today
i believe for the first time in the
history of the daily cancellation i'm
going to pull somebody
from the opening monologue and drag them
down here to the daily cancellation
sarah spain the sports reporter who
unwittingly recreated a seinfeld episode
while also claiming that gay people will
be denied housing because a professional
baseball player didn't wear a rainbow
patch
must be canceled today her obnoxiousness
and stupidity
are just too rich too expansive to cover
in one monologue but i want to retried
the same ground here there's a deeper
point that i want to make that i've been
thinking about actually
and uh this provides a you know a
starting point of jumping off point
it won't shock you to learn that spain
who condemned players for not showing
respect for the lgbt flag
has repeatedly over the years defended
kaepernick and his decision
to not show respect for the american
flag
spain has called it disgusting
nauseating repulsive that kaepernick
hasn't been offered a job in the nfl
after washing out seven years ago um
back when he first began that virtue
signaling campaign spain wrote an
article on espn in support of the
gesture calling kaepernick's critics to
task she wrote at the time quote i look
forward to the day when people stand up
and demand justice for people with the
same passion they display in defending
symbols standing for the anthem is easy
because it's expected loving your
country enough to want to make it better
is real patriotism
yes why would you bother defending
symbols they're just symbols
unless it's the gay pride symbol of
course
wearing the pride patch that's also
expected and easy
but in that case spain and her leftist
cohorts demand that the easy and
expected thing be done all in deference
to what they consider to be our true
national flag which is the pride flag
this helps to illuminate something that
may seem confusing on the surface
the left so often
seems to stand against
unity against the collective against
traditions against
symbols that bind people together they
seem to have a vision of the atomized
individual set apart from the collective
they applaud a guy like kaepernick for
declining to stand with his teammates
for the flag in fact they seem to
emphasize
individuality to the extent of actually
wanting each person to have their own
universe their own truth
forget about shared symbolism they don't
even accept that we have a shared
reality
if you watch what is a woman you know
how far this kind of line of thinking
can go or you could just watch any tick
tock video to get the same idea here's
one of a woman
who explains how her identity and her
pronouns continually evolve to the point
now
that her pronouns change
depending on who is talking to her
listen
happy pride everybody i already
mentioned this in my story but um i've
added a new set of pronouns to the
pronouns that i'm comfortable being
called i've been sitting on fay fair
fairs pronouns for a while and honestly
kind of psyching myself out about it i'm
like oh do i really want to like change
this again and then i like realized i
was like
who cares
like if i decide that i don't like them
i can just stop using them my other
thing about this new set of pronouns is
that i would only like for queer and
trans people to use them for me cishet
people they them queer and or trans
people you can use they them or fair
it's all good with me i'm excited
because fair pronouns make me feel very
affirmed in my not feeling like a person
sorry by the way that was an instagram
video not tick-tock didn't mean to uh
misgender tick-tock uh by the way
fay-fare pronouns are associated with
fairies so she identifies as an actual
mythical creature sometimes depending on
who she's in the room with
and we're expected to affirm that
reality
because it's her reality and she gets
her own reality for herself
this would seem to be
hyper individualism a kind of
individualism on steroids or perhaps
individualism on crack cocaine as the
case may be
you can't get any more individualistic
than to provide each individual with
their own universe to operate
inside of and yet
it turns out that this individual has
limits it's rather stifling in its
limits
so for one thing
we all get our own truth and yet
i'm not allowed to have a truth where
only women give birth
right like if i want my truth we all get
our own truth okay
so my truth i'm going to stick with the
truth and we'll just call that my truth
if you want for the sake of argument and
in my truth you know men are men women
are women
but you're not allowed to do that so you
can't have that truth
they reject that that is the truth and
they won't even allow you to claim it as
your own truth
we all have our own truth but some
truths are more true than others it
turns out we also find this supposed
individualism
doesn't even give us license to decline
a pride flag patch
it turns out that the individualists are
ruthless conformists
how can they be both what's going on
well it's because the individuality the
my truth stuff it's all a ruse it's a
front it's a tool
more like it it's used as a way to break
apart and demolish the institutions and
traditions that the left doesn't like a
child is encouraged to live his truth
because it will weaken the bond with his
parents
um spouses are encouraged to live their
truth because it will fracture their
marriage we're sent off into our own
universes in order to weaken and
eventually snap the ties keeping the
family the church the nation together
that's the ultimate objective
once it's accomplished
we're meant to reconvene back together
in one shared universe in reality only
it won't be the same one we left it'd be
like planet of the apes right we return
to the same world but everything is
turned on its head and all that was good
lays in ruins
now back here in this new world where
conformity is not just encouraged but
demanded and required our national flag
is the gay rainbow
the dominant religion is the religion of
gender the parent-child relationship has
been supplanted by the state-child
relationship
they said you could live your truth
but they really meant that
you must live theirs
which is an untruth
that's what this is all about
now i suspect that sarah spain hasn't
quite thought all of this out
she's just a ditzy conformist saying
whatever seems safest and most popular
in the moment
but
this is the agenda she serves
even if she's too dumb to realize it
and that's why she is today canceled and
that'll do it for us today thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day talk to you tomorrow
[Music]
the godspeed wall show is produced by
sean hampton executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavo
valdoski our associate producer is
mckenna waters the show is edited by
robbie dantzler our audio is mixed by
mike coromina and hair and makeup is
done by cherokee heart the matte wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 22.
today on the pen shapiro show matthew
mcconaughey joins the biden white house
to push gun control the washington post
implodes over a retweeted joke and makes
a total mockery of itself in the process
plus california liberals get mugged by
reality that's today on the bench bureau
show give to listen